[Music]
breaking it down we're taking your world
and we're shattering it in this video
you are going to learn how to make ghost
visual effects and make them really well
because I know how to do it I know how
to do it really well I'm gonna show you
exactly what I learned they're all kind
of the same effect but they're all
approached in different ways an easier
one I'm gonna show you a more advanced
one and they're both pretty cool it's
just over hot it's like you got an heat
lamp going on there but orange is colder
than blue at its core the best biggest
effects for this video were practical
and then we kind of worked backwards
from there doing visual effects when
necessary step one get a ghost girl yes
this girl Catherine she was actually in
Adrienne's Rock video we hooked you up
with Katelyn who designed a cool
prosthetic with big eyeballs we applied
it to her boom we got a ghost now we
need our ghost to be ghostly one of the
first shots I can show you how we did is
this shot right here where the little
ghosts hang us out and peeks out from
behind the lamp here now you're looking
at it oh wow that looks really easy
you're right actually you're hundreds
and right oh this is actually super easy
shot effectively we're doing three
things here tracking isolating and then
last but not least we're just doing a
little bit of filtering to make it look
out of focus that's all that's really
happening here well actually no there's
a fourth secret thing there's the fourth
thing is the secret sauce let's break it
down step by step step one its handheld
so we need a motion track in northern
motion track this footage make a little
image sequence bringing the MOCA I
basically selected the lamp here to
track it you're not gonna actually open
I guess I really should
so in mocha to track it I just generally
select the lamp here this is how most
works you literally click
that fast yeah as you can imagine the
shot eventually finishes you bring your
tracking data in you apply to a null
they have a null here in the scene that
we can track our footage to so it moves
around with our lamp step 2 is we take
our ghost our girls all look at that so
now here's our first separate element
here it's literally just here's ghost
girl against black we didn't actually
have the lamp there we have a little LED
panel and why did we shoot on black well
most of the time we're either using
screen modes or something like that
the ghost is supposed to be made out of
light so the black screen helps us
isolate the light parts better now that
we have that is we're just bringing it
back into our shot here alright so we
got a nice shot you can see my filters
here we have the noise reduction here a
little bit of levels to crush the black
sometimes I'm using this heatwave plugin
to give it a little bit of ghostly
ripple a little bit of chromatic
aberration and then last but not least
the crucial filter here out of focus
plugin from free sleuth
the best stuff the field plugin in the
world it looks real boom go through and
add a shadow you add that little shadow
makes it stop makes it seem like this
ghost is now actually there just a
little bit of that on the background
that helps and that's basically it in
order to make it spook here I use time
warp I'm using time warp to fluctuate
the speed of the character time or speed
affected to a wiggle expression so it's
constantly going faster and slower than
real time and that makes the motion kind
of cheat cheat cheat cheat cheat cheat
cheat kind of jitter so you see these
little stutters now in the motion
and compared to without it you know this
looks relatively normal and then this
looks relatively super normal paranormal
secret sauce it's the sweetest part of
every meal the secret sauce looking at
this I'm like alright what's gonna be
our secret sauce eyeballs we go into our
plate here boom boom just adding these
little gray discs here to the eyes what
are these great discs is doing what are
they doing that this looks stupid right
yeah it does when you bring it back into
this other cop here that's out of focus
that fries looked out of focus plugin I
was talking about the reason it's so
dang good is because it knows how to
separate highlights from shadows and so
when you have these white grit disks in
front of the eyes it knows spoke to them
a little bit extra now the eyes will
stand out put that secret sauce on top
call it a bay render tell me
answer me how long the life
the other 40% okay we're good
[Music]
this plant came from the Pasadena cactus
Center and Pasadena a hand-picked
everything I got ants up in my cactus I
hand-picked each one of these little
buddies and with the rocks and the whole
yeah yeah me and canva I really like
this guy is a nice little cactus in my
second plant like a little buddy to keep
alive and just got a water make sure it
gets air yeah I mean it's taken some
hits here on the tips I'm about to
replenish its life and elongate its life
with this water just like you guys have
elongated our lives really we wouldn't
be able to do this without you guys
because a lot goes into making these
videos a lot goes into paying myself and
Carmichael and Nick and Ren and Gabe and
and everyone at corridor so I'm a pour
some out for the top tier patreon
supporters fill up Oxford this one's for
you master one ace one this one boom
right there that one's for you
Nathan McFarland got your buddy right
here boom this is my favorite little one
right here too like that
Gary Dolph the centerpiece keeping us
alive oh yes you could see the water
down here drip it dripping down Nikolas
Sothis this doodoo little little spritz
for you beautiful G squared how could I
forget keeping us green fresh vibrant
Taylor Dunbar got a little little edge
little water edge water for you there
buddy
boom keeping this keeping this alive oh
how could I forget
Colin Heaton know em and forget you
buddy got you a boom my second favorite
plant right in there glitch cube just a
little little touch little extra touch
James Bailey
oh man I'm thirsty I'm thirsty James I
appreciate it Brian and toesik topping
it off just letting the life for through
these green succulents
so really appreciate your guys's support
I got ants on my toes it's a circle of
life I really appreciate you guys
donating your time your dollars to
support us give all of us a job and to
give all of us an opportunity to express
our creativity thank you thank you so
much
stay tuned I'll see you guys I
forgot to record them I hope dude that
would have been bad
[Music]
advanced-level
ghost effects now let's look at this
shot here and we're like okay this is
exactly the same isn't it same effect
right same old tricks in the books all
right you think that we did the same
thing no we didn't go stand on black
Time Warp gives it twitchy glitchyness
step two radically different radically
different we're taking a left
we're zigging we're sagging whatever you
thought we're gonna do we're doing the
opposite of it alright look at this look
at this look this what's going on here
there's a bright background and the
hands bright so if the ghost is made out
of light and we're putting it on a light
background well it's gonna disappear
right I was gonna use the same method it
look like that that's what this workshop
would have looked like if we went down
that same path but we did not so we're
actually going to create a luma matte
based off of the hand that means instead
of applying the screen composite mode
we're gonna make an alpha Channel so
it's physically there it's opaque so we
have our hand we apply color balance
make it black and white we apply levels
we crush it and make it bright and now
we use that same footage as a luma matte
for the hand this is physically there's
okay and that means that when we bring
in to the next shot it's going to
actually rest above the right footage
and so this is what our footage looks
like now we've dropped it in because
we're using the luma key we got a ghost
it up so we're gonna use similar effects
here BC color vibrance to make the hand
just a little closer to the color of the
light source we're use a color balance
to adjust it just a little further we're
gonna go down edge blur just to soften
it up a little bit and then once again
we go heatwave just to give it that
ghostly kind of little all right now we
have our facts boom Oh see even spookier
but once again if a ghost is actually
there in the shot should be creating
shadow right how do you create your
shadow it's real easy
take your same shot and then you just
make it black see I'm just literally
taking the hand here I take my footage
I'm s warp it a radio for Gaussian blur
make it black then tinted so that way it
matches shadows in the scene render
that's how you do it so that's the more
advanced version the rope effectively
the same effect but because of the
different circumstances you kinda have
to do them easy ways and in harder way
thankfully a lot of these shots were in
dark areas so we can just go screen mode
and it works button shots like this
where you start to interact with other
light areas you need to get into luma
masks and luma keying and actually give
that Ghost some some body the effects
both look really similar and you're like
oh it's a light-up Ghost pretty easy but
it's not the story that you are about to
be told
took place in the holiday world I'd say
it's time you
[Music]
[Applause]